this episode of congratulations episode
42 Monday November 13th is brought to
you by the cash app it seems that all
these babies all of our babies are
switching to the cash app as it's the
number one finance app in the App Store
they've introduced the cash card which
is very cool it's a black a new black
debit card that you can design yourself
and via the app and it allows you to use
the cash you keep in your app anywhere
you want plus it's the best way to pay
people back so I got it and you should
to download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now starting off by saying I've
got an app I've been my name in the
iTunes Store Chris D'Elia or you can go
to the link in my Instagram bio and you
can download the app that I have trying
to back up this [ __ ] Brinks
truck you're trying to help download the
[ __ ] app tired of these Brinks trucks
moving forward you know what I mean
let's get them to make let's get them to
make a little bit of a [ __ ] beat be
really cool to start the episode off
with a [ __ ] huge noise in my stomach
but whatever that's how it's going to be
listen this at this podcast that I do
III I [ __ ] veer off I talk about
whatever I talk about I don't have a
[ __ ] bullet points really sometimes I
have a few but like I don't today and I
I figure out what I'm saying as I'm
saying it and I'm not telling you guys
that to get any sort of like reaction
except for what I'm telling you what I'm
trying to tell you is sometimes it's
gonna [ __ ] you're not gonna
understand what I'm saying cuz it sucks
because I don't know what I'm saying yet
but we're all figuring out together
uh and that's what I like about this
podcast and I don't give a [ __ ] if you
like a like it or not it's what I like I
like doing it and if you want to listen
you [ __ ] listen and if you don't want
to listen you keep scrolling okay um you
just keep on scrolling baby there's so
many podcasts out there
you don't gotta listen to mine you don't
gotta listen to any podcast you can
listen to [ __ ] rock and roll all day
long
go ahead and listen to the [ __ ] Led
Zeppelin
everybody loves Led Zeppelin I couldn't
tell you a Led Zeppelin song if a guy
from Led Zeppelin was holding a gun to
my face saying what's one of my songs
I'd have zero clue what a Led Zeppelin
song is the only thing I know about Led
Zeppelin is they put the [ __ ] blimp
blowing up on their goddamn CD cover and
I feel you guys too when I'm here it's
like an audience that isn't necessarily
in the same room with me but when I'm on
stage I feel that energy and I talked to
you guys the way I I feel and you guys
[ __ ] laugh or you don't laugh back
and I [ __ ] use that I feel you out
there you're not in the same room but
you in your car in your cubicle in your
shower in your room you're in your dorm
and I feel you out there because you're
a true baby I wish I was a little bit
darker these days you know what I mean
first of all I'm pale as [ __ ] but second
of all being a white guy it's pretty
tough it's pretty tough this week yeah
[ __ ] under fire and you know it's
weird man the whole country is racist no
matter what I can't do anything about it
it's just how it is it's how it's gonna
be
if if one cop [ __ ] up all cops [ __ ] up
you know one [ __ ] Asian guy gets into
a car accident they all can't drive one
white guy [ __ ] takes his dick out all
of the white guys take their dick out
you know what I mean that's just how it
is and there's nothing we can do about
it there's no progress you know there's
no [ __ ] progress we're trying but not
really because everyone's got a goddamn
Twitter account everyone's got a goddamn
Twitter account and can tweet anything
that they think right away and that's a
[ __ ] huge problem to tweet something
that you think is [ __ ] a problem
remember writing remember having to
[ __ ] type it out put it on a paper
and going to [ __ ] print it that whole
time going to print it you thought maybe
I shouldn't [ __ ] print this and a lot
of people turned around a lot of people
turned around but now you think hey you
know what [ __ ] all white guys [ __ ] these
you know certain groups of people and
then you tweet it out and then everyone
[ __ ] swarms and agrees with you and
then all of a sudden everybody's you
know shitty all comedians are shitty now
because of what happened right and it's
fine to make a joke about it it's fine
it's it's [ __ ] good and it's funny
sometimes but you know some people are
like [ __ ] these people [ __ ] those people
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that think hey man think
do the drive if you're gonna tweet
something any anything anything this is
the rule if you're gonna tweet something
do a at least mentally before you tweet
it walk down into your car mentally in
your head go to the [ __ ] car drive
mentally take all the turns to the
nearest kinko where you were gonna print
it out get to Kinko's and mentally pay
for something to be printed then get it
drive all the way back and home and if
you still want to tweet it then to
if not don't people with this [ __ ]
I'm gonna say something right now Pam
dude it's out its out there in the
universe that [ __ ] could get retweeted
four million times
and are and there's enough crazy people
out there it doesn't matter people think
it's right people think you're right
people think you're [ __ ] right you can
say anything in this world and there
will be a group of people that think
you're right that's [ __ ] problem it's
a huge problem you're not right a lot of
the time a lot of times you're wrong
but if you're out in the Internet
there's enough wrong people out there
that it's gonna agree with you and now
all of a sudden you got a group you
don't deserve a group just because you
have a Twitter is it [ __ ] weird of
[ __ ] time man it is a weird weird
weird weird time god damn it it's so
weird I want to come on this podcast and
be silly as [ __ ]
I want to come on this podcast and talk
about how people are kouddous I want to
talk about how you guys are my true
babies I want to talk about how we're
backing up the Brinks truck together and
well how we're trying to get a [ __ ]
log cabin in the room I want to talk
about how its stupid people are dabbing
I want to talk about how it's stupid
people are [ __ ] wearing stupid hats
that's how I want to talk about but it's
hard when in my face there's so much
real [ __ ] going on
no Kudus men no kudus 2018 you got to do
the podcast how you're gonna do the
podcast man you can't come out here and
fake the room man comedians go out there
they fake the room they go out there
they don't fit you got to feel the
[ __ ] room out if you go out there as
a comedian and you [ __ ] and you try
to lift the crowd up to where you are
energy wise it often doesn't work so you
got to come back down and you got to
[ __ ] finesse them you got to massage
them you know what I mean you got to get
them a little bit horny sometimes you're
not horny you guys get a little bit
warning you gotta get the crowd a little
bit horny it's what you got to do you
got to [ __ ]
to do some and [ __ ] you know you gotta
[ __ ] seduce these [ __ ] you
can't just come out there
you can't just come out there and show
your [ __ ] deck you gotta have them
want it or they don't want it you go
home and that's okay some creds don't
want it um I [ __ ] slammed the guy
today dude let's let's get a little bit
light I slammed the guy today and you
know what I feel bad I feel bad that I
slammed the guy and I and I shouldn't
feel bad because I slammed the guy for
not doing his job but I feel bad man I
was at my [ __ ] mailbox Center thing
and I walk in and sometimes I forget my
key to open up my [ __ ] door the mail
door and I did and there's one guy
always there that has a problem with me
about not having the key so I was like
you don't have your key all right I'll
get it everyone else is nice and [ __ ]
yeah sure they're happy to come out from
behind the desk it's [ __ ] so simple
it's as simple you walk out you're
[ __ ] on do the thing and you give me
the thing
that's it so he came out and so I know
my god this [ __ ] guy he's gonna give
me [ __ ] cuz I'm around Mikey hey hey man
I'm Mikey can you open up I said I got a
package and he said hey man do you have
your key anymore and I was like yeah I
do you always asked me but sometimes I
forget and he says yeah I'm starting not
to believe you she's calling me a liar
so I said hey man you are care right and
he said yeah I said cool can you get my
mail and before he said anything I said
thanks hahaha it was the hardest slam
I'll do all week
it's Monday was the hardest Lam I'll do
all week it's a slam it dude when you
[ __ ] slam someone and then go Thanks
that's [ __ ] locking the door that's a
gunk and then I brought this key buddy
I'll lock it how about that how about
the slam I just gave you
I'll lock that door hey I brought the
key for the slam I just gave you lock
see ya hey and turn around in case I
opened the door back up I'll [ __ ] yeah
dude sit there was a soup
slam and and he didn't say anything and
I felt real bad I drove home felt real
bad made me realize I'm not a sociopath
I felt real [ __ ] bad cuz I should
have decay and I do it's somewhere in my
car but like you know help help me out I
pay for the [ __ ] service right people
don't wanna do their jobs I want to do
my job that's the thing and I understand
people are just lucky and feel good and
happy enough to get a job because it's
hard to get a job out there
not everybody can [ __ ] just throw
that's the other thing too I was
listened to a rapper on the radio [ __ ]
who was it
there was AMA my buddy rude dudes
[ __ ] thing on XM who's good you
should check him out but he was talking
to a actually I know I don't know if it
was reduce show but I wasn't in XM I was
listening to XM in the rapper was the
whoever what rapper rapper was he was on
he was like don't don't go for your
dreams he was basically saying he was
like he was like when I hear
[ __ ] tell other young people to
give up everything to rap he's like
that's terrible he's like if you have
responsibilities and you have kids and
you have bills you got to pay and you're
selfish enough to give it all up to try
and be a rapper you know you're you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that's what he was
saying and there is some merit to that
really I don't know I mean I don't have
kids on purpose I don't have a family on
purpose and so that's because I was
gonna focus on my [ __ ] becoming a
stand-up comedian I'm not saying that's
the right way to do it but I think
there's a right way for me to do it you
know but if I had [ __ ] three kids I
don't know you got to get you gotta get
this money you know I think that's the
rap mentality that's kind of the problem
they're like I get this money I'm gonna
do a rapping maybe you could
just getting a job a whole food so you
know get this [ __ ] $11 an hour dog
but yeah I was uh
so I slammed them and I felt I felt
alive when you slam someone you feel
alive
you really do that's the most alive you
feel right it's like feeling it's like
feeling it's like coming how a lot you
feel when you come right when you have
an orgasm when you have nor gasm how
alive do you feel you feel alive when
you see do you feel just as alive when
you slam someone but then you feel bad
afterwards it's a lot like orgasm and
slamming someone because you feel bad
afterwards a lot of the time unless you
were someone you truly loved dude how
about I just feel [ __ ] I don't know I
feel weird these days man everyone knows
you you know everyone knows you cuz you
got a [ __ ] I was at the I was at the
gym the other day how about I joined a
gym I know I think I touched on this
last episode nobody works out hard
nobody [ __ ] works out her dude when I
go to the gym I'm killing myself I'm
[ __ ] jumping on platforms I'm lifting
weights I'm running on the treadmills
dude I'm dripping wet it looks like I'm
in the middle of a fight I look horrible
they actually look alike actually I look
good because you look sweaty and [ __ ] I
think probably people think it's sexy
hey there's nothing I can do about it
babies I'm dripping wet my shirt my
t-shirts [ __ ] drenched I'm looking
mad sexy it's nice and I it's nothing I
can do about it I got pink shorts I got
purple shorts I got neon green shorts
and I got [ __ ] grey shorts and I got
black shorts and I rotate him and I
[ __ ] I look like I look I look and I
picked the [ __ ] corresponding shirt
and you know what
I'm not fashionable when I work out but
I sure I'm thinking about it but so I'm
at the gym and I'm killing myself these
[ __ ] don't work out they chat
they [ __ ] text they chat and then
some of these girls dude they were full
makeup when they work out skull
on what's going on you're not working
out that hard cuz your makeup will be
running [ __ ] they put on full [ __ ]
makeup almost like a drag queen
and then they go [ __ ] work out what
Oh also how about the [ __ ] that outfits
that's the thing I I got shorts and a
shirt here's what you work here's what
you use when you here's what you wear
when you work out dude
shorts and a shirt or those [ __ ] or
pants and shoes that's it here are the
things you don't want when you work out
jeans there's always a [ __ ] weird
albanian guy and every gym is for
working out with jeans on okay and he's
got like a dirty shirt who is that guy
you know I'm talking about every time
you go to a gym there's some [ __ ] guy
with jeans on and like a weird dirty
white shirt and he's like five foot nine
and and you're like what did this guy
[ __ ] stop in and just do some
pull-ups on the way to [ __ ] painting
a house you know that guy I [ __ ]
swear to god that guy's there at least
one out of three times you work out and
he never has a belt on either it takes
his belt off so it's like pants are
coming down and then here's another
thing you don't wear when you work out a
full on sexy outfit if you're a chick
hey there's no reason to see your
[ __ ] hottest [ __ ] cleavage I don't
need to be getting a horn when I'm
working out how about that oh [ __ ] I
need to be horny when I'm doing incline
why do I
have an orgasm when I'm jumping on
platforms hey do I have a jump rope in
my hand and my heart [ __ ] and the other
prob wear a matching thing fine but some
of these chicks are like showcasing
their titties I saw a girl taking a
[ __ ] selfie at the at the gym and and
she looked good she had a great body and
and I was like Oh for [ __ ] sake she's
taking this selfie for her Instagram
whatever whatever whatever
okay but then she [ __ ] started
killing it at the gym and I was like
dude it's me and her man we're [ __ ]
killing it together dude I mean I don't
even work out near her but I kept my
[ __ ] like I was like imma go harder
because that girl's going hard she was
jumping rope throwing the ball [ __ ]
doing the situps
doing [ __ ] different side to side
with the balls and then she did the
[ __ ] treadmill after that dude
jumping up and down doing the ropes that
[ __ ] thing killing it man I was proud
of her I even know her oh there's one
guy that [ __ ] he's so big and he has
those you know those here's another
thing you don't wear at the gym you can
wear a tank top kinda but if you have
that real skinny tank top that's
basically just a piece of floss in
between your two titties your nipples
dudes well you got like this dude is so
big and he's got a tank top and I swear
to god the tank top that he has is it it
goes in between his nipples it always
shows his nipples like that [ __ ] one
like the G like this string one and his
nipples come out it always shows his
[ __ ] nipples hey don't show your
nipples at the gym there's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] cover your nipples bro the [ __ ]
are you doing
cover your nipples at the gym if you're
a guy or a girl cover your nipples and
we're showing you the [ __ ] on the video
podcast I swear to god we can't even
find one that's that's it's way less
than that it's like three inches
skinnier than that it's it's literally
like a shoelace in between his [ __ ]
breasts and then it widens out down near
his waist and he was a dummies [ __ ] like
bandana that only covers like it like
comes up and like it's like get it
together bro
get it together you Lee Haney you Lee
Haney no I all want to know what these
guys real jobs are besides [ __ ]
nutrition's I've got all these guys
working nutrition shops or they all work
in nutrition cuz it's funny to me to
think about that guy a guy who's so into
fitness but then he works out at like at
Ralph's he's a manager like a [ __ ]
grocery store and he just is dying to
take off his [ __ ] shop right polo to
go put he's like dude I [ __ ] hate
covering up my nipples at work dude I
can't wait to get to the gym and get
that [ __ ] shoelace in between my two
[ __ ] titties and just work the [ __ ]
out and if you're a guy and you got the
short shorts and the [ __ ] ass cheeks
are hanging out huh hey if you're a girl
and you have that working out huh but if
you're a guy and you have that working
out huh harder huh
what are you doing show me the bottom
yes I don't need to get a horn
whether I'm straight or gay at the gym
[ __ ] shirt look at that shirt look at
that shirt we got to show that on the
video pocket no you know my favorite is
look at the way he's with lifting up his
[ __ ] pants I love when they [ __ ]
guys at that they do it on Instagram all
the time when they lift up one leg to
show the [ __ ] quad or when they put
their pants down a lot of guys take
their their go they'll be in the locker
room and their pants will be down and
they're under will will be up so it just
shows like their [ __ ] all bunched up and
they're [ __ ] hiking up so you can see
their quads hey man you know that's fine
just [ __ ] Lee
your underwear the way it is don't hike
it up so I can see your dick and balls
all huddled together nobody works out
hard at the gym and people are wearing
makeup and and [ __ ] it's just
so I was at the gym and somebody said
hey as I was leaving
all sweaty and [ __ ] breathing really
hard some lady came up to me hey you're
uh hey you uh you unfriended me on
instagram first of all she doesn't know
the [ __ ] terminology okay so already
I don't know what the [ __ ] she's talking
about
you don't ever friend someone on
Instagram no maybe I thought no now what
that meet what that I think anybody
would think that means is I unfollowed
her on Instagram which I never followed
her on Instagram I don't know this lady
so I said i unfriended you on Instagram
and she said yeah I said Facebook and
she said no Instagram and I said uh
meaning uh I said I never followed you
and she said yeah you blocked me and I
said okay that's what she means
so got her to say what she meant and I
said oh well yeah you must have said
something rude and she said no way I
never said anything rude and I said oh I
only I only block rude people and she
said well I didn't and I said yeah you
did
and I walked away that's it the [ __ ] am
i blocking her for being know why the
[ __ ] would I block anybody
she said something shitty and I blocked
her and then I walked away and here's
the other thing - it's [ __ ] the UH
the uncomfort
billet uncomfortability is that a word
uncomfortability uncomfortability
whatever it's a [ __ ] word now when
somebody
oh yeah like when somebody want one time
this was [ __ ] seven years ago when
people try to make you uncomfortable
with some [ __ ] that they're gonna bring
up I [ __ ] love that I [ __ ] eat
that [ __ ] for breakfast bro I eat it up
I love it one time I was at the Laugh
Factory it was [ __ ] years ago and
this girl came up to me in front of
other people
and said to me hey you asked me to hang
out on she was a facebook friend and we
were [ __ ] whatever she was like yeah
you you asked me to [ __ ] hang out on
MySpace or [ __ ] Facebook or something
and she thought she was gonna make me
embarrassed in front of her friends and
I [ __ ] it felt I felt like I became
the Hulk and I looked at her and I said
yeah yeah yeah I did yeah
and I [ __ ] hung it out there too I
hung it out there to dry dude you're
gonna hand me some [ __ ] wet laundry
dude you're gonna hand me some [ __ ]
wet laundry like I don't have a [ __ ]
clothesline are you kidding me she
thought she was gonna [ __ ] make me
feel uncomfortable
in front of a bunch of guys and girl she
came with at the Laugh Factory about
hanging out and she thought I was gonna
[ __ ] stand there with a wet sweater
like oh what am I gonna do with this
nope I [ __ ] looked at her in the eyes
and I said yup and I threw that [ __ ] in
the dryer and guess what she felt
[ __ ] stupid after that she didn't
know what to say she goes up yeah dude
you're gonna make me feel uncomfortable
I got
in judo moves with that [ __ ] man I've
bombed in front of 450 people at the
Irvine improv you think that you're
gonna come up in front of seven people
and say hey I remember you used to ask
me to hang out on Facebook or MySpace
and make me feel cold B you think I'm
gonna do a hard swallow for that give me
all the laundry I'll dry it [ __ ] all
it's not it's not gonna work dude it's
not gonna work I love it I love that
[ __ ] I eat I'll eat it I'll [ __ ] eat
it do it I'll eat it I'll keep it in my
stomach for four hours wait till it
[ __ ] forms [ __ ] it out and deliver it
back to you baby
how about that I just these people when
people come up to me hey man what's up
what's up hey you don't remember my name
huh I look at him and I say nope hey how
about this be memorable I think we
talked about this on the podcast that
part but be bent be memorable if I don't
remember your name
your fault
how about that if I don't remember your
name sure don't put the blame on me man
I'll dry laundry all [ __ ] day
I have clotheslines for weeks what's my
name
you don't remember huh I step sturdy you
you understand I step closer to you and
you know when the handshake is supposed
to end it
doesn't end there i grip you can't get
away hey what's up what's up man how you
doing all good hey Chris you remember
our name huh oh we do it my hand I'm
holding it and I'm stepping in and I'm
saying no that's how it should be it's
not my fault I forgot your name and
guess what if I met [ __ ] the guy who
cured cancer and he said hey what's up
I'm Rick I'll never forget that guy's
name
you know why memorable you know why
Samara ball okay if I remember some
[ __ ] dump truck of a man if if some
dump truck of a man comes up and it
already knows me and I already met him
and he says what's my name huh
hey who are you who are you hey do you
live in [ __ ] Albuquerque cuz who are
you
who the [ __ ] lives in Alcor Albuquerque
guys like that guys who you forget their
names
sorry Albuquerque had to pick some city
see you all that [ __ ] aren't working
[ __ ]
Albuquerque yeah dude you're not blaming
[ __ ] me for not knowing who the [ __ ]
you are dah dah dah dah yah I'm loving
it
you're not blaming me Brown here we go
babies time for some ad reads time for
some at reads thank them for some time
for some ad reads time time for some
time for some ad reads you know that red
men song time for some action
so annoying dated myself alright here we
go
me undies dude if we're talking about
favorite products of the century here
every year me
people receive the least like gift of
all time underwear but we still give it
to our family and our loved ones who
just don't want it but maybe it's not
the underwear that's our problem it's
the kind of underwear I'm telling you me
undies is the kind of underwear that
changed the game in underwear it makes
for an amazing gift it really does you
might you might not think so and then
when you put them on you realize it you
get it then it's the best me undies is
the best it feels amazing
around your trunk dude it's my favorite
underwear I've ever worn by a longshot
it's the best gift that everyone is
gonna they're gonna love you for it they
are they are I've turned people to me on
on to me undies and they were like dude
they hit me back that they have it has
nothing to do and we're not talking
about it no hit me back to be like dude
that me on these huh they're it's
awesome this holiday season to get your
exclusive 20% off the softest underwear
and socks you will ever wear free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
comm / Congrats that's my undies comm /
Congrats me undies dot-com / Congrats
tracker wallet phone keys these are the
things you always leave you can't find
and when you leave the house it's hard
to figure out where they are whenever
you leave the house it turns into the
world's most annoying scavenger hunt but
eight years ago tracker spelled tra ck
are changed everything when they
released their new their first tracking
device and now they've done it again
with their all new tracker pixel when
you misplace an item that has a tracker
pixel attached you use your smartphone
and a 90 decibel alert will help you
find it in section seconds you find it
even in the dark cuz it's got an LED
light lose your phone just press the
button on your tracker pixel and your
phone rings even if it's on silent and
trackers 30 day money-back guarantee
means you truly have nothing to lose
go to the tracker dot-com / congrats and
get 20% off any order that's th e TR a
CK are.com / congrats for 20% off the
tracker dot-com /
it's great so we do not more or do it
all right that's it
every time I start a new ad my producer
is supposed to put click start the timer
and each ad is supposed to be a minute
he didn't stop it and start it in
between the first two so it went over
two minutes one fire so many fireable
offenses one fire dude one fire you know
that's somebody's name for real one fire
he gets emails that say hey Juan how
hilarious is that don't even put fire
you know how disrespectful that is hey
Juan hey Juan when's the podcast up you
know it's disrespectful he's gotten a
m-- this guy named Scott ney it's
annoying
I don't know what else man
[ __ ] I got involved when I was talking
about that [ __ ] laundry shed I'm
gonna be in Columbus Ohio this week so I
was home for about three weeks
well no two-and-a-half after Australia I
got a lot of uh material from Australia
which I'm happy about I got about 15 new
minutes which I'm tinkering around with
I've got over an hour now
and I don't know if it's I gotta figure
out what I want to do with the next hour
I don't want to rush into a special I
just had had one come out and I don't
know most of my act right now is about
my dogs because I just been sitting
around with them and but uh yeah all the
shows in Columbus are sold out I added
another one and it sold out but it's a
is it really a four hour and 20 minute
flight I hate these [ __ ] make the
planes go faster make him go faster you
can you can I know you can Elon Musk the
only one trying to [ __ ] figure [ __ ]
out I feel like he's the only one that's
trying to figure [ __ ] out now this guy's
like yeah yeah you'll be able to go to
[ __ ] Singapore in three minutes
and we'll be like how I will shoot a
rocket up into the moon and then it'll
come back down and you'll be there in
three minutes it's longer yeah but it's
thinner this bits thinner the airs
thinner up there that's my favorite [ __ ]
when people say you can go faster
because the airs thinner up there which
I is true but also it like mate like
well I go we got will [ __ ] murky air
down here it's air you know it's not
[ __ ] Nickelodeon gak it's the second
time I brought up Nickelodeon gak in
this podcast and I've it's the second
time I brought up Nickelodeon gak in my
life
so weird but yeah Elon Musk the only one
trying to figure [ __ ] out oh my god dude
how about Donald Trump's [ __ ] tweet
about the know about it was a Kim Jong
was that what it was about hey I can't
believe he called me old I never called
him shorten I could call him short and
fat dude Donald Trump okay but you are
old why would Kim Jong hoon insult me by
calling me old
that's not insulting to call somebody
old he's 71 what's old a hundred and
thirty oh well I tried so hard to be
let's just break down how did how little
boy this is why would Kim Jong hoon
insult me by calling me old how about
this is real why will Kim Jong listen
replace it with Kevin why would Kevin
and assault me by calling me old when I
would never call him sure and then fat
oh well I tried so hard to be his friend
and maybe someday that will happen that
sounds right to say it like that
I love always looking at the tweet under
Donald Trump's tweet it's always
negative to him and this one that says
how the [ __ ] are you in the White House
so funny how how that's weird to even
not even to be the president and do that
but to just be a person and tweet that
is weird I think people are like it's
got to be a joke right I don't know if
it's a joke the guy's a lunatic look I
don't give a [ __ ] if you're Republican
or Democrat I mean I'll tell you this
man these [ __ ] liberals these a lot
of these liberals are policy ass
[ __ ] whine and ask crying ass
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] grab your
[ __ ] grab your [ __ ] junk and sack
the [ __ ] up man I'm not telling your
liberals or right or whatever the [ __ ]
but this guy what who what the [ __ ] is
he doing
man that's so [ __ ] funny man
and and you know what it's not - it's
sad as [ __ ] it's [ __ ] scary - hey guy
I don't want to get blown up don't want
to get blown up yeah weird times we're
living in man it's so weird at the times
we live in now sometimes I don't look I
look at a you know you see it you got it
now or it's like you see you see a you
see a pretty girl and you're like ah
[ __ ] I hope I didn't [ __ ] assault her
by staring too long you know I hope I
hope she doesn't I'm she's gonna tweet
about how i salted her because i stared
at her at [ __ ] Whole Foods crazy man
it's crazy when a really beautiful woman
walks into a room though
because the whole atmosphere changes
everything changes no matter what
whether you're a girl or a whether your
girl the room is full of girls a room
full of guy flow guys the room full of
guys beautiful woman walked into a room
of course guys notice no no did you see
them in sometimes oh and some guys are
gonna be pervs hey check out the tits
look at the ass right some guys are
gonna be like wow look at that lady
she's amazing all the guys are gonna
want to be with her okay that's just how
it works
science human but when the beautiful
girl walks into a room and there's girls
there a lot of girls are gonna be like
wow I bow down a lot of girls gonna be
like wow that girl's a [ __ ] just for
being but some guys
feel like a girl you know what a girl
work works in and she's so hot and you
walk in and you're just and the guy
thinks like oh [ __ ] Heather
sometimes a girl so how she works in
room I think I'll have the family with
her now
to trap her to [ __ ] trap her so she's
always got to be connected with me like
how girls [ __ ] trap dudes and put
holes in condoms or [ __ ] say they're
on the pill but they're not secretly on
the pill like they're like yeah I taken
a 9 a.m. every day but they don't they
[ __ ] up and they take it at 10:30 some
days and then you [ __ ] squirt it in
them and then they have a kid and
they're like sorry I take the pill and
you trapped them that's how hot some
girls are I want to trap them by having
sex with them and for nine months being
like hey look over here and then it'll
be like wait what the heck I'm having a
baby and then be like yeah you're mine
now hey hey what's up Playa jeweled play
bejeweled I think I got something going
on no no just here play minesweeper
there okay and then till it's like five
months in and she can't get rid of the
baby and you're like oh okay I guess
guess we're just gonna guess we're just
gonna have a family then and you knew
full well you trapped her I don't know
when I was a kid and Britney Spears was
the [ __ ] I thought I would I and I
thought this and I meant this I thought
I would I would marry Britney Spears
right now without knowing her and live a
life with her and now I know that that's
the worst idea in the world because you
don't know somebody how can you marry
them but that
uh I remember thinking that that's how
you get [ __ ] that's how you make
those decisions when you're [ __ ] 18
or whatever like what if what if I I
said that and for some reason that
fantasy just can't became reality and
Britney Spears like yeah let's get
married and we had a family and I was
[ __ ] married to Britney Spears right
now I probably wouldn't want to be I
probably would have been like I was a
real [ __ ] knee-jerk reaction I'm
getting a [ __ ] panic attack right now
with the [ __ ]
hey guys gonna read some more ads here
so we can back up this [ __ ]
Brinks truck it seems the look square
cashes is the best here all right it
seems that all of my true babies all of
the true babies all of our true babies
are switching to the cash app it's the
number one finance in the App Store so
let's get involved it's the best way to
pay people back friends family coworkers
Kudus sending and receiving money is
totally free and fast here's how it
works you download the square cash app
link to your debit or credit card select
an amount to send type in a friend's
phone number or email address complete a
payment they'll get a notification that
they just received money that's it no
gimmicks Square cash is better than the
other guys it's not a network it's not a
social network you don't have people
don't know when you're paying somebody
for trash bags or whatever the cash card
is cool it's this new black debit card
that you can design yourself with the
app it's a real physical card that you
use to keep cash in the app anywhere you
want and you can pay for it with the app
like a regular credit card you get
notifications from for all payments made
with the card directly with the cash app
it's very cool it's futuristic you wanna
be from the future use this cash up and
laser-etched your card to personalize it
and it'll be delivered to you for free
like you're a king download the free
cash app for iOS or Android now I want
to talk to you guys about something
called man crates okay look it's real
hard to pick out the perfect gift for
not even just for anyone for guys it's
practically impossible for girls you get
nice thing you get things you know what
girls walk
but guys these man crates ended that man
crates calm the surest way to find gifts
that guys were actually love it isn't a
cheese of the month or a new tie I mean
imagine getting these guys that that
those those those suck man crates offers
a hundred hand curated gift calanque
collections for every type of guy from
the rugged outdoorsman like me to the
sports fanatic like me and everything in
between like whiskey appreciation crate
with a personalized decanter and glasses
for his favorite drink were the
grillmaster crate with a brass knuckle
meat tenderizer and a cast-iron smoker
box I mean what Dad what guy wouldn't
want this these things there's a lot of
there's a hundred different ones go to
man crates calm and look at them pick
out the perfect crate and choose the
delivery date I've seen the website they
got a hundred different things it's
amazing when his crate arrives he gets
to pry that box open with his own laser
engraved crowbar it's really manly both
men's health and Allure magazine are
saying man crates are the perfect gift
for men and these two don't agree on
anything because one's men's health and
one's allure they have thousands of
five-star reviews and every man crate
comes with a 100% satisfaction guarantee
own the holidays go to man crates calm /
congrats and get five percent off your
order that's five percent off at man
crates dot-com / congrats man crates
dot-com / Congrats remember in the end
the episode where I went do them mature
lure I forget what that was for just
taking your dick and balls out Wow how
times have changed huh don't do that
mature lore anymore huh hey don't take a
dick and balls out anymore huh I
remember someone was saying hey it
forgot if a girl wants you to take her
dick out she'll ask
imagine if that was the world we lived
in hey I would like you to take your
dick out at this point oh cool
huh read the signs better that's all
read the signs how about if someone's
legs are crossed don't take your dick
out yeah
or if you know in public leave it in if
you're in the car kissing or if you're
not kissing don't take your dick out I
guess if you kissing in the car or if in
a place with a bed in it you can start
to maybe slowly unzip your pants maybe
it's a real gray area here though you
know you can't really [ __ ] navigate
it where everyone's gonna just keep
getting in trouble because there is so
[ __ ] great some people are [ __ ]
crazy out there you'd be kissing and
[ __ ]
hey if a girl
take your dick out she'll ask huh that's
not the world we live in that's insane
but yeah be more responsible guys on
taking the old dick out yeah taking the
old dick aronia all right here we go
quit I I love this company you don't
need a big expensive toothbrush to get
the oral care you need you don't you get
the same refreshing clean with something
simpler that'll give you the best
brushing experience you've ever had the
words exciting and toothbrush have
literally never been used in the same
sentence until now quip it's the new
company that's refreshing the way people
brush their teeth I use it I take it on
the road with me it's an electric
toothbrush quip that packs premium
vibration and a timer and and timer
features into an ultra slim design and
it's half the cost of bulkier brushes
it's like it's like if Apple designed a
toothbrush really kind of but without
the big price tag you have to see it and
brush it with yourself it's awesome you
can even subscribe to receive new brush
heads on a dentist recommended
three-month plan for just five dollars
including free shipping quip is backed
by a leading dentist that was named one
of times magazine's best in best
inventions of 2016 they won a 2016 GQ
grooming award and made an on oprah's
2017 New Year's o list quip starts at
just $25 right now get to go to get clip
comm / congrats to get your first refill
pack with free quip electric toothbrush
go to get clip comm / congrats to get
your first refill pack free with equip
electric toothbrush first refill pack
free that's your first refill pack free
at get clip calm / Congrats GE t qu IP
comm / Congrats dude
so I was somebody sent me this one dude
somebody sent this one I got to get
right into this this is so funny to me
hey guys it's time for the most [ __ ]
up Instagram post of the week
[Music]
alright dude
now this one is amazing okay it's just a
guy who is now picture this guy he's
standing near act know he's I don't have
he's sitting her stand as a selfie but
he's videoing himself near a kangaroo
the kangaroos in the background just
being a kangaroo okay and it's a video
and the caption is pure amazement so
that's what this guy's good now this is
what this guy is saying I'm just gonna
play the video for you and and he has
got to be a hundred percent high if he's
not it's even better okay this is what
he says these moments in which you
experience afresh the hardly bearable
act to see of direct energy exploding on
our nerve endings he's of course
referring to a holy moment Otto ranks
mysterium tremendum a fast scene awesome
as Tim duty wrote during these moments
of in which we utter exact you lations
of amazement we get to recontextualize
the self as a marvelous conduit in a
timeless hall from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
back again we transcend the bin there's
and done that's of the adult mind one
awaken to our common ecstasy we
[Music]
what a [ __ ] utter ik stack you
lations utter extractions
google.x accusations a stack you lations
I mean literally your search extact you
lations did not match any documents have
you ever googled something that's never
had results
what a [ __ ] half hard [ __ ]
this guy is dude this guy's gotten laid
you know this guy has had a conversation
in business he's standing near a
kangaroo I mean what is this guy saying
and he laughs like he's making a joke
like he said like he like did yo dude
what are we gonna play again he talks
about these moments in which you
experience afresh the hardly bearable
act to see of direct energy exploding on
our nerve endings he's of course
referring to a holy moment Auto ranks
mysterium tremendum a fast scene awesome
as tim duty wrote during these moments
of the self as a marvelous conduit in
the timeless hall from which molecules
and meanings flow from neurons to nebula
and back again we transcend the bend
there's and done that's of the adult
mind we awaken to our common ecstasy we
it literally means nothing
does that mean anything what does this
guy think it means literally expecting
extact you lations and transcending the
bin there's and done that and a half
knots in the world
Timothy Kaczynski row
[Music]
we talks about these moments in which
you experience afresh the hardly
bearable acts to see of direct energy
exploding experience afresh the hardly
directed energy this autorange
experience it sounds so much like a
robot right there
Otto rakes experience in the tremendous
Amana furious wholesome exploding on our
nerve endings he's of course referring
to a holy moment anytime someone says of
course like that he's of course
referring to you're a [ __ ] such a [ __ ]
dude exact you lations of amazement have
you guys ever experience text
accusations of amazement experienced
afresh the hardly bearable ecstasy of
direct energy exploding on our nerve
endings he's of course referring to a
holy moment Otto ranks mysterium
tremendum a fashion awesome as tim duty
wrote during these moments of in which
we utter extensions of amazement in
which we utter extact you lations of
amazement let's see what else
Natalia was telling me that she
discovers shots of uh during a time in
her life when she was really kind of
hungry for some kind of answer or
something I smiled it what a [ __ ] what
is huh in psycho dynamics I'm interested
in how different places and spaces and
people everything you have to take into
account with your sensory apparatus
informs your subjectivity in other words
your experience has to take into account
where you are and who you're with right
you become what you behold as McKenna
said we are the some of the people that
will spend the most amount of time with
but if we're interested in creating need
to be craftsmen of our fate we need to
filter out the wrong crowd we need to
customize our spaces and places to
unfold this is experience design take
into account the [ __ ] is this saying I
mean I have X accusations of amazement
right now dude what is he saying just
the way he's talking and just we are
just the lump sum of whatever who we
hang out with right so what is exciting
about this whole pepper and I am bored
sports mordom a podium is basically what
okay so what Galileo said was we're all
walking a mile around and amongst us we
have all the external
a hard drive of the mind so to speak
it's what we do we plug into the
extra-terrestrial somewhat of a dark
matter I've been laid four times that
guy probably gets so much a plus dude
IIIi could I here's the thing about me I
can listen to this guy all day and just
be laughing and crying and [ __ ]
loving it now I know that a lot of you
guys are like alright this guy's come on
man don't [ __ ] come on talk about
other things but how can I do that what
there's this guy how can I do that
oh this guy Fox I like this guy are you
like this guy I actually like this guy
no irony Internet we are drowning in
information every two days we create
more data and all of you in history up
until that point so information keep
therefore intention has become expensive
the currency of our age is attention
attention is the new oil if you can't
retain eyeballs if you can hold on to
people's focal what is he saying like
it's Shakespeare why is he saying it
like he's in a oh for [ __ ] sake dude oh
[ __ ] I gotta hang out with this guy dude
here's the thing man this is why I like
this guy
you have to be passionate man oh [ __ ]
this guy's blowing my mind not in the
way he thinks he's blowing my mind
this guy is walking down Runyon Canyon
which is a hiking place in Hollywood
doing these these videos I mean he's
nonsense words this guy in a way [ __ ]
man
like he said to hold on to their focal
point anything the best part is he
thinks it's funny and he's laughing dude
iiiii I can listen to this guy all day
goddamn and he's so passionate about the
[ __ ] uh oh my god this guy rocks he gets
a follow so funny dude
I remember actually seeing him on a
thing on TV and I thought
god damn man I mean they got to him I'm
sorry I gotta take that guy took me
[ __ ] to task bro the best part is
when he laughs at his [ __ ] you know it's
oh man how about people who are just so
[ __ ] always telling you quotes that
other people said as McKenna said as as
as Tim the Toolman Taylor mentioned Wow
whoever DM me that guy thank you
really the what a treat man you [ __ ]
made my life better I'm [ __ ] a howl
and I was almost crying there Jesus
Christ that was like [ __ ] made me
laugh harder than the Michael Caine I'll
bow it then Michael Caine's website I'll
[ __ ] imagine Michael came in him in the
[ __ ] room together
Oh stack you lations of amazement
ultimate do you want to do with stack
you lations Michael Caine oh alright
let's look at some of these questions do
it for [ __ ] sake mint clout Stav Oh at
gust in Flynn may or okay whatever too
many letters thoughts on friendsgiving
now you know if you know anything about
me you know absolutely not
you can do it don't call it
friendsgiving i don't you know the words
are the words we're using the words the
way the words are okay it's Thanksgiving
with your friends friends giving there's
some corny [ __ ] uh what does that even
mean that one kami kami be at kami be
one
do you ever take too long on the toilet
you have to shut the water off in the
shower huh [ __ ] are you talking about
what take too long on I think it means
like he started and then go to the
bathroom and then you got a what what do
you what do you mean in the middle of
taking a [ __ ] you got to get up and do
just finish your [ __ ] how long are you
[ __ ] I mean
that's happened now what glad you asked
that go to another one I obviously don't
want to have that one but look at the
one my producer just had up on the
screen go ahead go back go back
do you like it when you hold your poop
in I mean one fire dude this guy [ __ ]
puts it up do you like it when you hold
it you thought that was a good one for
me to answer one fire what a [ __ ] would
I want to answer them look at this one
hey Chris and [ __ ] made it so I
couldn't see it hey Chris D'Elia I
really just want a slam well you have to
be deserving of a slam to get a slam
sometimes when I slam my friends on text
chains I sent him a picture of a door
that's the door slamming in their face
they're no good ones huh blue this one
just oh my Michael Caine somebody just
alerted me to this one Michael Caine
Michael came to Eden tweeted I am a
chilled night on a warm night click that
April 2011 Wow
oh man you know what's weird is like how
famous Michael Caine is and then he's on
Twitter and has like probably like
200,000 followers we already did that
one last week I feel like yeah we did
oh my god that guy [ __ ] killed me
dude you don't have anymore you can pick
any good ones there were no good ones
nope nobody [ __ ] game the system
today really that well you guys are
asked a stupid [ __ ] like do I like it
when I hold my poopin although I read it
what was that one that go up I mean yeah
you guys oh here that's a I just saw
some I don't know how about when people
do inside jokes to people you know what
a pet peeve of mine is is when you're
with seven people and somebody does a
joke that you have with one other person
that and the rest of the sick people
aren't gonna get don't do that it's not
worth it you're making every you're
making the more of the people
uncomfortable it's not worth it for the
guy the one person haha Plus that person
feels uncomfortable cuz the other people
don't get it you're not doing it right
you're not doing humor right not doing
go to the website and get the know CUDA
shirts man they're out look at them if
you're on the video podcast you could
see that [ __ ] no Kudus men cuz this 2018
coming up and dude up you got to get rid
of these kouddous no barracudas 2018
that's the [ __ ] thing 2018 no
barracudas baby no barracudas so yeah
I'm gonna wrap this up dude I'm a mouse
I laughed so hard oh we got a new Elder
babies you want to talk about a new
elder here we go
introducing a new elder this is probably
like the seventh or eighth one
eat Minh at Gabe etemon why that's G a B
or maybe it's at gah beat Minh made a
youtube video that made me laugh that of
the super mario song I was singing on
the episode 31 fried butterfly so yeah
we'll DM you with the details man but
congratulations from congratulations
congratulations from congratulations for
your certificate and pin it's coming to
you gay beat Minh or beat Minh so thank
you
that [ __ ] made me laugh it was for his
like class or something he had to do it
and it was pretty killer dude you looked
up on YouTube super mario theme song
congratulations with Chris D'Elia Chris
D'Elia
alright so uh let's wrap this up Square
cash you got a switch download the free
square cash app design your cash card
get it for iOS or Android now let's do
it
join me join me babies join me babies
subscribe to my youtube channel getting
more and more hits on the YouTube videos
it's fun to to watch we cut in some
stuff with it and so if you if you if
you want to watch the videos watch the
videos go get some merch and then see
where it at the show's baby you khuda
know Kudus congratulations shirt you'd
the [ __ ] tired Eagle sweat crewneck
er you know subscribe rate and review
the show tweet me at congratulations
powder use the hashtag congratulations
pot video episodes go up Tuesdays or
Wednesdays upcoming shows babies
Columbus Ohio
Irvine California San Jose California
San Diego new show added in San Diego
that's going quick so make sure you
[ __ ] you get on that Riverside on New
Year's Eve come celebrate New Year's Eve
with me
Winnipeg we added a second show those
tickets are almost gone figure that out
and Calgary we're going to man on fire
my special if you haven't seen it yet
you got to go watch it and thank you for
listening and remember you
stack elations remember dude extractions
of amazement is the key to life thank
you guys for listening
you guys are my baby
[Music]